[Music]
stallonus
these guys are taking this person you
were only supposed to create a diversion
Roman that was complete destruction what
you want for me I'm Roman Pearce man
it's what I do
Chris to Phase two what's phase two
pounds away
you know what I like about you dawn
they're genuine outlaw but your family
the hell of a job brother
when we get back to the base beers on me
he's about to go up against the only
thing they can't handle you did you ever
think you'd betray your family the way
you did today Dominic Toretto
just turned on us well well well you
look at that I don't know why he's doing
this
well that wasn't done she's the very
definition of AI tech terrorism and now
she's working with your guy I think I
found my team this should be interesting
where I got
oh this is impossible which is why
they're gonna need a little help I will
beat you like a Cherokee drop longer
than I expected
if you gotta catch dawn you guys are
gonna work together surprise I just fell
in love I've been waiting for this we
got a tank
let's roll I don't know if the old DOM
is in there I don't give a damn I'm
taking you down so right out let's play
why are they shooting at me I don't know
maybe because you're always laughing
[Music]
we are about to go on
see we're gonna need a bigger truck
don't you're gonna turn your back on
family
[Music]
I live my life a quarter mile at a time
nothing else matters
those 10 seconds or less
the open road to take you anywhere to
friends to family we know he's an
O'Conner but he's also a Tyrell Salalah
for adventure let's do it
to see something new what do you mean
dream just to come back home again the
facet of here is saga has explored the
endless possibility of the open road
from the streets just outside downtown
Los Angeles we've taken you to Miami
we've taken you to
reowww London Abu Dhabi and now our name
is known all over the world we have
raced for speed race for honor queue
dawa's had you greens our cities tumble
down mountains and even dropped out of
the sky but no matter how our adventures
grow fast and furious is always about
one very important thing
family the most important thing in life
will always be the people in this room
saluton if Ania
our family of characters do everything
for each other and with each other for
the millions who make up our global
family advance we push ourselves to go
further and do better time after time
we never ride alone we never ride alone
this time it ain't just about being a
[ __ ]
now we embark on our next chapter our
family will be challenged like never
before by adversaries who show no mercy
testing that bond that has always kept
us together
most ambitious most entertaining fastest
and most furious Rania
this is fast and furious
you
you